I'm born and raised in LA.
I'm 19.
I'm working, I'm not going to college.
It's a big choice to make, but I'm satisfied with it.
I'm working for a fashion company and I'm doing celebrity PR for them.
It has its ups and downs.
It's definitely a challenging job.
We do our best to dress everyone.
And we're constantly filtering through requests that we get from different stylists...
...for premieres or for award shows or photocalls, things like that.
It's a lot of emailing, but it's fun.
I think that fashion is a really cool thing...
...because it's constantly changing and it doesn't really ever take a break.
Once you've seen one season or one collection,...
...within a couple of months there's a new one.
So, it's fun to just always have something new.